seilbahnunglück in italien mindestens 13
menschen sterben beim absturz einer
gondel am lago maggiore hoffen auf einen
fast normalen sommer für weitreichende
öffnungen peilt gesundheitsminister
sparen
eine inzidenz unter 20 an wieder
erstklassig bochum steigt in die erste
fußball-bundesliga auf und auch fürth
feiert die rückkehr
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend herzlich
willkommen zusammen mit norbert könig
für den sport zunehmend es ist ein
pfingstsonntag auf den einen dunkler
schatten fällt am lago maggiore in
norditalien sind die ersten selber an
unterwegs um touristen in die berge zu
bringen
heute stürzt eine gondel kurz vor dem
gipfel des monte motor ohne hunderte von
metern in die tiefe
mindestens 13 menschen sterben zwei
kinder sind in kritischem zustand
warum die kabine abstürzte ist noch
unklar
christoph distel eine der steilsten
stellen am berg hier ist es gegen mittag
passiert 300 meter vor der gipfelstation
ein seil ist wohl gerissen die gondel
stürzt in die tiefe
fast alle drin sterben zwei kinder 9 und
5 jahre alt überleben schwer verletzt
sie seien in kritischem zustand heißt es
die helfer kommen kaum an den absturz
ort müssen am abhang durch den dichten
wald weil es weder straßen noch wege
gibt nach einer person suchen sie noch
auf sie soll in der gondel gesessen
haben
es ist eine tragödie mitten im touristen
im piemont am lago maggiore wo das
grundl system die menschen eigentlich
vom arzt reeser hoch auf den monte motor
ohne auf fast 1500 meter bringt so sah
das aus als alles noch gut war
in 20 minuten vom sie zum berg damit
wirbt der seilbahnbetreiber und
verspricht eines der schönsten alpen
panoramen dass es gibt erst vor ein paar
jahren wurde die seilbahn frisch
renoviert stillstand sie zuletzt nur
wegen coruna seit gestern dürfte sie
wieder in betrieb
es sollte der neustart aus der pandemie
heraus seien auf dem weg ins
unglücksgebiet versicherte pyrmont
regionalpräsident italien sei ein land
der sicherheit und forderte
schnellstmöglich zu klären warum die
gondel in die tiefe stürzte
nach belarus da sorgen die erzwungene
landung eines flugzeugs und die
festnahme eines oppositionellen für
internationale kritik
so verlangt die eu die sofortige
freigabe des flugzeugs und aller
passagiere wegen einer angeblichen
bombendrohung war die maschine zu der
lande
benötigt werden an bord des fliegers der
im exil lebende belarussische
regierungskritiker und journalist roman
botta cilic er sitzt nun in haft
die wogen schlagen hoch international
für begann in moskau eine quasi flugzeug
entführung in europa um einen
journalisten festzunehmen das sind ganz
neue methoden ja und es zeigt wie weit
alexander lukaschenko bereit ist zu
gehen um diejenigen in seine gewalt zu
bringen
die er für seine feinde hält an bord der
maschine waren ja neben dem journalisten
eben auch noch etwa 120 passagiere aus
halb europa die eigentlich von athen
nach vilnius wollten und sich plötzlich
inmitten einer notlandung wiedergefunden
haben prothese wird
der lebte schon seit 19 2009 10 im
ausland weil er sich in belarus bedroht
fühlte und auch heute morgen soll er
doch einen bekannten geschrieben haben
er habe das gefühl dass der
belarussische geheimdienst ihm auf den
fersen sei in belarus werden ihm jetzt
volksverhetzung und die anstiftung zu
massenunruhen vorgeworfen
darauf stehen sehr lange haftstrafen
seine mitstreiter aus minsk allerdings
die schrieben uns vor hin
sie befürchteten dass romandie haft
womöglich gar nicht überleben würde
ursula von der leyen hat per twitter
konsequenzen angekündigt der evg
vorsitzende nannte das alles ein akt des
staats terrors und der polnische
präsident möchte morgen auf dem
eu-gipfel über mögliche sanktionen
diskutieren viel empörung also unter
europas politikern doch die alleine die
worte und die tweets die werden lukas
schenk wo sicherlich nicht beeindrucken
vielen dank für begann nach moskau zum
thema corona da setzt
gesundheitsminister sparen neue
zielmarke für den sommer eine inzidenz
unter 20 und schülern will er bis ende
august ein impfangebot machen
bis zum beginn des wochenendes haben
fast 40 prozent der deutschen ihre erste
impfung erhalten
und das sind die aktuellen corona zahlen
das lka meldet 6700 14 neue fälle
innerhalb eines tages das sind fast 1800
weniger als vor einer woche
82 menschen starben die bundesweite
inzidenz
auf 64,5 mehr von an seinem stern
vieles ist wieder möglich viel hat
wieder offen pfingstwochenende in
deutschland es sind alte freiheiten die
zurückkehren und die sich irgendwie ganz
neu anfühlen wie beispielsweise ich hier
in hamburg
mehr corona lockerungen der
bundesgesundheitsminister spricht er
heute von neuen zielmarken eine inzidenz
unter 20 solle angestrebt werden mit
blick auf den vergangenen sommer da
waren die zahlen sehr niedrig allerdings
nicht sehr lange
es kam die zweite welle damals haben die
auslandsreisen häufig verwandtschaft
besucher in der türkei und auf dem
balkan phasenweise rund 50 prozent der
neuinfektionen bei uns ausgelöst das
müssen wir in diesem jahr verhindern
sagt jens spahn und fordert neue ziele
auch beim thema impfen schüler zwischen
12 und 16 sollten bis ende august ein
impfangebot bekommen mit bayern tag doch
noch ist der impfstoff für jugendliche
gar nicht zugelassen und auch sonst
viele fragen wer sollen impfen kinder
und jugendarzt wäre natürlich die
naturgegebenen impfenden aber ob diese
menge an kinder und jugendlichen in der
kurzen zeit schaffen würden alleine sei
mal dahin gestellt die anderen praxen
sind schon reichlich beschäftigt
reichlich beschäftigt mit den vielen
erwachsenen die dran sind mit impfen
die noch warten auf einen impftermin und
auf mehr normalität im sommer 2021 zum
pfingstfest in corona zeiten haben die
großen kirchen in deutschland zu mehr
miteinander und mut aufgerufen
der ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen
kirche bedford strohm sagte die pandemie
habe den menschen grenzen aufgezeigt das
könne aber der erste schritt für ein
gutes leben sein
der vorsitzende der katholischen
bischofskonferenz bätzing betonte glaube
sei eine helfende tröstliche kraft in
der krise nach berlin wo steigende
mieten und verdrängung von langjährigen
bewohnern schon lange ein problem sind
ein gesetz zur deckelung der miete war
in der hauptstadt beschlossen wurde
jedoch vom bundesverfassungsgericht
kassiert heute nun sind tausende auf die
straße gegangen um gegen den wie sie
sagen mietenwahnsinn zu protestieren
sylvia bleßmann
es ist die anhaltende wohnungsnot und
die angst vor verdrängung die die
berliner auf die straße zog friedlich
demonstrierten sie gegen erneut steigen
die mieten in ihrer stadt
die unzufriedenheit ist extrem groß weil
vermieten deckel tatsächlich eine
wirksame maßnahme war gegen das immer
weitere steigende mieten und dass er nun
weggenommen wurde hat die wut und die
zufriedenheit stark vergrößert ich war
enttäuscht wurde weil es war ein kleines
instrument gewesen um die leute mal luft
zu verschaffen bundesweiter mit deckel
muss höher
das ist ganz klar wenn der bund nicht
reagiert könnten initiativen wie die zur
enteignung großer konzerne mit mehr als
3000 wohnungen populärer werden in der
stadt die berliner aktion hat schub
erhalten sagt der mieten deckel vom
bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt wurde
so initiatorin nun sagen viele leute das
jetzt erst recht man die enteignungs
kampagne unterstützen muss weil man
keine hoffnung mehr haben kann das mit
nieten besetzung ist ein temporäre
lösung hier in berlin gefunden wird und
dass wir dann jetzt eine radikalere
lösungen brauchen mittlerweile kann sich
fast jeder zweite berliner enteignungen
vorstellen mieter gegen vermieter die
stadt ist extrem polarisiert ich finde
dass gerade am tag des grundgesetzes
ganz wichtig dass wir das recht auf
eigentum auch weiterhin hoch halten und
das was hier gerade in berlin passiert
ist eine umfassende enteignungs
offensive für einen volksentscheid sind
175.000 unterschriften nötig der könnte
zeitgleich mit den wahlen im september
über ein enteignungsgesetz entscheiden
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
fordert bei judenfeindlichkeit höhere
strafen antisemitismus auch der alltags
antisemitismus ist ein schweres vergehen
so söder gegenüber der funke
mediengruppe der zentralrat der juden
kritisiert das deutsche strafrecht lasse
ein vorgehen teils gar nicht zu täglich
gingen etwa 50 hass nachrichten ein
nach angaben seines präsidenten schuster
gehen viele absender so vor dass sie für
die verbalen angriffe nicht belangt
werden
im osten der demokratischen republik
kongo hat einen vulkanausbruch in der
zwei millionen metropole goma panik
ausgelöst
der gewaltige lavastrom kam jedoch kurz
vor dem stadtrand zum stehen
bei der flucht vor dem feuer spuckenden
vulkan kam es jedoch zu zahlreichen
unfällen
dabei soll es mehrere tote gegeben haben
gestern abend in rotterdam nach zwei
jahren zwangspause fand der eurovision
song contest wieder statt
unter strengen auflagen konnten 3500
negativ getestete zuschauer das
spektakel vor ort verfolgen im
wettbewerb zeichnete sich in diesem jahr
ein klarer zweikampf zwischen
energetischen rock und französischem
chanson ab ein kopf an kopf rennen am
ende mit einem außergewöhnlichen sieger
dominik schepker berichtet dieser song
hat europa begeistert die band monaten
rockt auf der bühne fast so wie früher
[Musik]
es ist der erste esc sieg für italien
seit 31 jahren knapp dahinter
frankreich und die schweiz
für deutschland singt jendricke don't
feel hate 0 punkte von den zuschauern
vorletzter platz wieder ein mal kann
deutschland in europa nicht überzeugen
3500 zuschauer sehen die show in der
halle ohne abstand ohne maske ungewohnte
bilder nach 15 monaten pandemie aber
rein geht es nur mit negativem corona
test hat ein gutes gefühl und corona das
nicht das ende voll war so von daher wer
sind glücklich bei den isländern gibt es
einen corona fall von der band wird ein
aufgezeichneter auftritt gesendet die
musiker müssen isoliert im hotel bleiben
die show ist in diesem jahr besonders
vielfältig ganz unterschiedliche genres
zum beispiel französischer chanson
[Musik]
die fast so als würde der wettbewerb
wieder grandprix heißen
musikalisch ist es einer der besten esc
es seit langem
[Musik]
die beiden direkten aufsteiger in die
fußball bundesliga stehen fest und einen
kann man wirklich als alten bekannten
bezeichnen arbeit ja denn der ist echt
schon zum siebten mal aufgestiegen
der vfl bochum macht alles klar mit
einem heimsieg gegen sandhausen ist nach
elf jahren zurück im oberhaus greuther
fürth steigt ebenfalls direkt auf
holstein kiel muss in die relegation
vor dem stadion feierten zahlreiche
bochumer fans ausgelassen die rückkehr
ihres vfl in die erste bundesliga nach
elfjähriger abstinenz bochum genügte
eine routinierte vorstellung um sich mit
dem 3 1 gegen sandhausen den aufstieg in
die a 1 zu sichern dass sich auch die
spielvereinigung greuther fürth den
direkten aufstiegsplatz verdiente darf
durchaus als überraschung gewertet
werden umso mehr als die franken die
zweite halbzeit gegen düsseldorf nur
noch zu zehnt durch spielen konnten und
sich trotzdem mit drei zu zwei
hauptsitze frust und enttäuschung
dagegen in kiel wo die holsteiner bei
einer 1 0 halbzeitführung gegen
darmstadt den aufstieg schon greifbar
vor augen hatten
nach der 2 3 niederlage aber müssen sie
nun auf bessere zeiten in der relegation
hoffen dann gegen den ersten fc köln
erstes kleines erfolgserlebnis für
sebastian vettel in der formel 1 wm 2021
erholt als fünfter in monte carlo seine
ersten wm-punkte beim sieg des
niederländers max verstanden im
fürstentum von monaco zeigt sebastian
vettel nach langer zeit wieder seine
klasse
hier links von einem boxenstopp comment
liefert sich vettel ein
kopf-an-kopf-rennen mit pia gas li und
lewis hamilton vettel kämpft lässt
tatsächlich die beiden hinter sich und
holte am ende als fünfter erstmals im
aston martin wm punkte souveräner sieger
max verstappen unter den augen von
schale claire gestern auf der pole
position heute nur zuschauer sein
ferrari mit getriebeschaden max
verstappen übernimmt mit seinem sieg
auch die wm führung weil mercedes pilot
lewis hamilton als siebter enttäuschte
die handballer des sc magdeburg stehen
im finale der european league gegen
bundesliga-konkurrent füchse berlin beim
final four turnier in mannheim gewannen
die füchse gestern abend gegen gastgeber
rhein neckar löwen mit 35 zu 32 zuhörer
magdeburg mit 30 29 gegen wisla plock
aus polen erfolgreich so petra danke
schon mir gerne und wie wird das wetter
am pfingstmontag an den alpen und im
westen regnet es vor allem am nachmittag
örtlich gibt es auch gewitter im osten
bleibt es trocken
die temperatur erreicht 13 bis 20 im
osten 20 bis 24 grad
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie um 314 zum
heute-journal und wir sehen uns morgen
abend um 7 wieder wenn sie mögen nach
noch einen schönen zweiten feiertag bis
morgen